Hey, this is another one of those. We
predicted it, but then when you read about it,
it's like even worse than what you imagined, we
have now learned that employees at Donald Trump's
Chicago Trump Tower were all vaccinated early
well before they were eligible. And interestingly,
this may not be about Trump specifically, but
it probably is. We're not completely sure yet.
And you'll understand why in a moment.
The vaccination at this Trump building
was arranged by a hospital CEO that lives in
the building, and that's 37 year old Anoush
Ahmed. Seventy two employees of Trump's hotel and
condo tower received vaccines on March 10 and 11.
But city guidelines say that hotel employees
aren't actually eligible for vaccination until
March twenty nine. So they were almost three weeks
early. The mayor, Lori Lightfoot, said, quote,
We have a finite amount of vaccine in the city.
We've been really, really careful to make sure
we're using it in a way that prioritizes the
most vulnerable people who are most at risk
and most at risk of spreading it, adding, we
can't have something like this happen again.
Now, the hospital itself is located in a mostly
black neighborhood nine miles from Trump Tower.
It claims that its mission is to provide
vaccines to the minority communities hardest hit
by the coronavirus pandemic. But what
happened is vaccines were taken from
there and
brought nine miles
to Trump Tower. It's sort of the epitome of the
worst of the worst. Now, is it just coincidence
that it's Trump Tower? What I mean by that is,
OK, the CEO, a Akhmad, lives in the tower, and
maybe it was just what he would have done
regardless of where he lived. And it has nothing
whatsoever to do with the Trump family except
that I know Ahmed bragged that Eric Trump
was one of the individuals vaccinated and there's
even a picture of them together, although it's
not immediately clear if this picture is from
Vaccination Day that we are currently showing
the audience, Ahmed also to others, a picture of
himself posing with Eric Trump. On March 13th,
Eric Trump tweeted two pictures of the Chicago
Tower in the city skyline, which confirms that
he was in Chicago right around the days when this
vaccination at Trump Tower was supposedly taking
place. So it's not looking particularly good. The
hospital initially said, oh, we were confused.
We thought that hotel employees were
already eligible, but then we found
out that they weren't really eligible.
That seems insanely difficult to believe.
If you're going to drive the vaccines from
the hospital to Trump Tower and you don't
even know whether you're not even going to really
check whether the hospital workers are eligible.
They said they thought that the hospital or the
hotel workers, rather, were eligible. So that
imploded. So their newest statement is that, well,
listen, even if they weren't yet eligible, a lot
of those 72 vaccinated Trump employees were black
and brown, which is just sort of like now you're
going to pull the race card yourselves as the
story crumbles. So it all stinks. This is just one
story and there are
hundreds or thousands of stories just like
it. Most don't involve Trump, by the way, read
up on what's happening in Argentina, where I was
born with
vaccinations. Anything
you can imagine is happening there. Functionaries
of the government are being caught with literally
thousands of vaccine doses in the trunks of their
cars. When they're asked, what are you doing with
that, they're saying, oh, I was transporting them.
You're transporting vaccines. That doesn't really
make any sense. The governor of the province of
Buenos Aires. So want to say it's almost like New
York City and state. You have to say site is
the city and you have to say it is the province.
The governor of the province of of scientists has
been involved in under the table vaccinations for
prominent people. They even there's there's like
a prominent Argentinean authors and intellectuals
who reported they were offered vaccines, even
though they don't qualify, they live in the
province. I mean, this stuff is rampant globally.
It was only a matter of time until one of these
vaccination scandals touched the Trump family.
And this is the first one we know of taking place
in Chicago. So we'll see what else we can learn
about it. One week from today, Friday, March 26,
very special day.
We start spring break for The David
Pakman Show. No, but in all seriousness, we're
doing a one day membership special, February, the
first part of March. It's not been great from the
standpoint of memberships. A lot of people writing
saying, David, I've got to cancel. I just can't
afford it. I'm cutting this, I'm cutting HBO,
I'm cutting cable and I get it. So we are
doing. A huge one day membership special Friday,
March 26th, if you want to hear about it on the
day of with instructions about how to sign up,
get on my newsletter at David Pakman Dotcom.
And Friday morning you'll get an email telling
you exactly how to sign up. We'll take a quick
break. We will hear from you. I want to hear
what is on your mind. We will take some calls via
discord momentarily and much more coming up today.